hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Anna's ohms
great early worth of manalo join as well
as running throughout the rest of his
works one of the you might say guiding
metaphysical perspective assumptions is
what we call the doctrine of
participation yeah and I've got two
places on the board where he's actually
invoking this explicitly chapter 1 and
chapter 16 but it runs throughout this
work it's something that you might say
it ties everything together he's going
to be exploring and making use of this
doctrine so it's important to understand
this not necessarily to agree with it
but certainly to understand this if you
want to be able to make sense out of
what's going on it adds films works and
you want to see the arguments that he's
putting forth is in any way reasonable
at all you don't have to agree with them
as a matter of fact in our current
culture or current intellectual milieu
the doctrine of participation is not
something that that many people find
particularly plausible but you know has
just been discussed by people who pay
attention to these developments
throughout history that's not necessary
the reason to rule it out there's some
great literature out there I'll maybe
put a link to that in the description of
this video now this is a key assumption
or doctrine and I could hear of
Neoplatonism or if you just want to call
it platonism in a general sense not
necessarily explicitly tied to play
those texts themselves these these
medieval philosophers you know around in
Psalms time didn't they actually have
access to most of Plato's works but they
did know about Plato through other other
authors and this is a metaphysical
assumption or doctrine it tells us about
how things are in you know after basis
connected with each other and its
assertion about the reality of what we
might call certain universals or certain
ideas if we want to use Plato's term
certain forms and before I go into the
actual doctrine itself I do want to say
something why would this be so plausible
for the ansem this is in part because
the medievals themselves particularly
the early medievals are pretty much all
platon asst and that's not just in
Western Europe that's also in the East
as well you know the Byzantine Empire if
you look at early Christian thinkers the
people who would go on to become
influential for later medieval thinkers
like Ansel you're going to find that
many of them are indeed to one degree or
another playlist so for example st.
Augustine who somebody who handsome will
pick out by name in this work one of the
very few references that he makes to
anybody coming before him Augustine is a
Christian
playtest and so he finds this doctrine
of participation plausible and saw
himself is is you know going to be
following that path but we easy is who
is coming a bit later another very
important Christian plainness
philosopher also you know accepting this
but it's not just those guys it's sort
of part of the milieu the intellectual
milieu and so where some of the things
that Anselm is saying may strike us as a
bit implausible or a naive they weren't
so and it's also important to keep in
mind that Ansel isn't just accepting
this doctrine and then saying all right
never going to think about this again
he's actually you know taking it as sort
of a hypothesis and seeing what can we
we go to its very basis what can we draw
out of it in terms of its
intelligibility particularly out of
thought in terms of a Christian
metaphysics that he's working out it is
more alone g so that's enough sort of
historical background and cautions about
dismissing it too too easily let's talk
about the doctrine itself he says here
here's a sort of generic way to look at
it for certain matters not for every
single thing but for certain manners at
least some of the ones that turn out to
be most important in metaphysics in
moral philosophy in other areas as well
like goodness for example or justice or
be it this is going to be a particularly
controversial aspect of this for modern
philosophers being itself is something
that we beings participate in but for
certain matters there is some I put your
X itself like goodness itself or justice
itself or being itself then those things
participate in an some is going to call
this supreme goodness or Supreme justice
in this work but you could just as well
use the four moments if you like that
sort of plate
construction or you can talk about you
know justice itself justice with a
capital j however it works for you the
basic idea is that those things
participate there there's sort of you
might say knock offs or copies or they
have an element of whatever that X
itself is but they don't have the
fullness of it and they are what they
are precisely not because they have you
know some sort of absolute fullness and
substantiality themselves but because
there's this other thing out there in
which they in some way are connected
through through participation so the
goodness of good things can ultimately
be traced back to goodness itself which
is what in the last analysis makes them
good so that's quite a lot to think
about already now let's take a look at
these two passages from the motor oil
gym where where it becomes a very
important point for for the argument so
in chapter one he's not actually
interested in justice itself at this
point more interested in talking about
goodness and how we can make sense of
good things and the multiplicity of them
and whether they're there is some sort
of supreme good that they're all
participating in he uses justice as an
example to say look this is what the way
it is for justice it's going to be
something similar for goodness so he
says just things are just through pair
in Latin through justice they're not
just just by themselves they're not just
because people happen to call them just
they're not just because we had a sort
of sentimental attachment to them or
they fulfill certain social utility
functions or anything like that they are
just ultimately that I mean those other
things could be true they are just
ultimately because they participate in
they have some of the
sure of they take on the pattern of they
imbibe the quality / we think of it of
justice itself of justice that really is
something that that exists and hands of
being at its own the only an important
part of this is he notes that that
justice Capital J justice it is the same
in all these different things so for
example the justice that I happen to
have in my soul what degree of that I
have or that I enact in my relations
with other people here in the 21st
century is not the same justice as that
which handsome who by the way was an
exemplar for justice in his own time I
actually got faulted by some of the
other ones from being maybe perhaps to
adjust which is a contradiction in terms
for him but it's not exactly the same
thing as the justice that he exhibited I
exhibit justice towards say my students
my family members my my wife my pets my
neighbors he exhibits justice towards
his fellow monks towards the King
towards the nobles and the common people
that he interacts with and so on and so
forth right they're not the same thing
but they are identifiable as the same
thing because there is a common essence
or a common core a common structure
within them and that is justice itself
that they participate in so justice
itself is we can say a universal under
which many particulars can be brought
and identified as justice it's not just
in this passage allowing us to identify
sameness in diversity or unity and
multiplicity it's also important for
another reason and I didn't put this on
the board but it is really worth
stressing when we have something like
justice itself in individual things
those individual things can be more or
less just they can participate more or
less in that quality in by doing so we
by noting this we are comparing them how
are we able to compare them we are
comparing them by making use of this
justice itself this this justice in
which they participate we're using it as
a measure or a standard without really
realizing that we're doing so unless
somebody calls our attention to it as an
some dozen motor launch in chapter one
chapter 16 is also very interesting
because there he's looking at the divine
attributes which were going to discuss
much later in a further video and he's
interested in talking about what is it
to have the quality of justice he
contrasts the case of God from the case
of a human being a human being he says
can have justice can have that quality
of justice they can also have injustice
right and they came more justice or less
justice there's you know a whole range
of possibilities for us human beings
what quite interesting isn't it and he
says human beings can have justice is
equality here's the question we can ask
whether we want to ask it of God or
whether whether we want to ask it of
some sort of generic Lathon form does
that justice itself justice with a
capital j does that ham justice or is
the word have in Latin actually honorary
inadequate and applicable there and
misleading the answer is yes to that
last question justice itself doesn't
have justice it is justice and this is
where Ansel calls it something quite
interesting that only shows up at this
point in his work he calls um justice
itself existent justice
stands in Latin word that he doesn't use
an awful lot exists today but it talks
about this is existing justice trying to
stress to us the fact that this is where
justice in its full sense really resides
and not just as an ideal quality but it
has the very being of justice the very
existence of it so that is simply
justice this is also really central to
the doctrine of participation if animals
you might say what's the upshot of this
if you want to understand the quality
that you say something has you need to
refer it to what it is that it
participates in at least for certain
qualities not enough for others that are
you know merely relative or primitive
right but for certain qualities like
justice or goodness you're going to have
to do that here's where it gets even
more controversial be being itself is
something in which beings like
everything around us like you like me
participate in to some degree and we can
have more or less being I am reserving
that for a later video because that's a
particularly interesting doctrine as
well that plays an important role in
ansal about physics but this is a note
for you to understand the doctrine of
participation and the importance that it
has within an Psalms works so that as
you approach the Mona lo June it will
make a little bit more sense to you if
you keep this in the back of your mind